our next two stars will present the  award for the best achievement in sound  one of them won an Oscar for a role in  which she never spoke a word thereby  making life very happy for the sound  technicians the other made life rather  tricky for them by parting the waters of  the Red Sea with appropriate sound  effects Jane Wyman and Charlton Heston  the nominees are Samuel Goldwyn studio  sound department for I want to live  Tadeo sound department for South Pacific  Universal International studio sound  department for a time to love and a time  to die  paramount sound studio department for  vertigo 20th Century Fox studio sound  department for the Young Lions and now  Chuck open the Aqua and the winner is  South Pacific  Tadeo sound department  in behalf of the toddy or sound  Department I accept it Thanks